hi I'm Sean Bennett a course architect
with Udacity I'm Cole McCandless
developer advocate at Google
I'm Peter lubbers a program manager at
Google now html5 has a rich suite of
functionality to build amazing
experiences on the web this course is
about leveraging those tools to build
fun engaging games now cult here is
going to be acting as our game expert I
like games and peter is going to be
acting as our html5 expert I love html5
now there are two different ways you can
enter this course if you are not already
familiar with JavaScript or modern
browsers then we have an optional
JavaScript crash course for you to take
now if you're already familiar with all
of that then you can go ahead and skip
that and go straight to our canvas unit
can't wait to see you in class